hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and I should be ashamed I haven't seen
this this is like a cult classic I've
never seen that do you even know what
it's about
no I just know there can be only one
that's all I know oh I in my mind have
this very specific idea of what the
movie is but reading the kind of
synopsis of it on the Amazon screen it's
nothing like what I thought it was so I
know I do what this movie is gonna be I
just know something about Sean Connery's
in it swords they're to be only one
something about Scotland and the sequels
really bored that's all I know and one
of them is called the quickening cuz
that's the stupidest time we does the
music I know that bad I just found out I
didn't know that so that makes me really
excited also this is Tamara's never seen
[Music]
you
we shoulda came back from it and just
like had come into frame whoo we got
talking about the shots yeah so yeah
let's talk about what this movie was
about Tamara go ahead thank you so much
thank you for giving that to me I just
saw the old it but I no idea what the
hell just happened what the whole time I
think I said what I think we were always
afraid like cuz obviously we make jokes
and we talk about the movie but we're
just like did we do that too much or we
just miss this man isn't this random
giant wrestling show do you mean just
live it to himself he is pissed off that
wrestling is fake yeah he's just
watching like son of a bitch it was real
with Hulk Hogan was in there is
Neanderthal brow just dominates every
scene until everyone else shows the
wrestling show he goes into this open
car lot with like garage with all these
beautiful cars and then this guy shows
up in a sword fight in the middle of a
New York garage and he's dressed like
Agent Smith but like 20 years old
clearly not fit to be doing the flips
and sword fighting that he's doing
though they don't really source fight
rail in this the stage combat isn't
great that's why what it looks like
stage combat it looks like two little
kids who are fighting for the purses
there's a lot of this and a lot of this
like that's in there but the stuntmen
doing flips wash away too many flesh the
answer is it's too many flips but yeah
all the fighting is like a and
and to see you and Perry how are you the
Highlander are you the one because he
doesn't die it goes back and forth
between and the 80s you see a little bit
spliced in between of like earlier times
than that and later times that but
mostly to those two time frames and it
goes back and forth back and forth and
he's like learning how to be the
Highlander from Sean Connery who's just
fabulous that's the word a special
creature and this he shows up like every
scene starts and ends which is like two
people talking like we're just talking
like you just see like you know uh goose
or Lambor they're just thing is suddenly
beer bottles like he's like a tied up
and people are throwing shit out it's
like where did this come from a scene
literally explodes the people are
talking at some point there's a few
dragging voice with those transitions
are like fine yeah I'm in it now and the
shots in this movie is my favorite one
here we recreated all right so woman
comes that I think I named candy or
Chrissy it's just and she says of course
you are
as my favorite you're talking to this
woman trying to save her it kept you on
your toes because you kept waiting Frank
just somebody's head to pop yeah I it
was a figurative and literal blast
that's whatever they're doing they are
so into it and they are just doing
everything to make this shots look cool
in the editing cool and then just like
hey this guy's a bad guy well what's he
do well he kidnaps this woman they just
rides on the street on the sidewalk for
no goddamn reason let's go just go I
feel like whatever anyone recommended in
the stone cemetery was like oh I want
this shot to start down here and then it
goes down here and it goes like into a
person's eyes and out their asses like
yeah do it like to just do it whatever
you want to do I don't they did well
they did really well and the things they
did were just like so weird like the
evil guy I loved him but his prosthetic
was a blaringly terrible like the worst
prosthetic I've ever seen but they've
kind of leaned into it like they added
some paper current safety pins it's a
it's about as good as the old way make
up later when he's watching like his
girlfriend died and literally all they
did they just put a few wrinkle lines
okay for a white wig and she's like yeah
and she's dying they shoot her in the
dump why does he sound like tommy was so
I don't know the one that Ojai Lambert
just like him his lap exactly I do it
like hahaha like it looks like it me
sounds like fast don't talk too much I
love them
yeah it's like every time it's like
trying to think back to all like just
the crazy scenes it mixed in with like
you know some beautiful cinematography
but then just something totally insane
like I can hear that else hard and then
just him and Sean Connery running on the
beach like the best romance in the world
like I can hear now it's hard is the
quickening wasn't anything you never
know what the quickening really is and
there's a scene okay so like where you
know he's meeting this woman in the 80s
and he's convincing her that he's
immortal
that immediately means they have to that
happens while they've spent scenes and
scenes and scenes with him and Sean
Connery being sensual as hell they have
the most chemistry and I refuse to
believe that the people in LA were that
were them in the 80s it was clearly
Chris Lambert and Sean Connery I mean by
car I mean I really did love it at the
end like you know there's the big battle
where they just go like this over and
over and and it looks like he's defeated
that then the girlfriend comes in to
like knock him once if they come say
he's like what kept you like suddenly
that's like you spinach for some reason
like that gives them the strength and
then like when he kills them like
suddenly turns into like Black Cauldron
like all these things are going into
like white pink elephants or something
like that and then the windows explode
everything cuz of course they are it was
just like the only thing that would make
this like even crazier as the Queen
actually came in playing the song
through the window yeah he's like the
Dragonborn of humans like in take
in the souls it doesn't look great but I
believe it you can see the strings
holding it all didn't even try to show
us this is how we're doing the effect
the only time where I was getting out of
his whatever cuts bag to like the
eighties it's like the cops or her
trying to do research on it like that
shit's boring because like we just saw
Sean Connery as the Scarlet Pimpernel
and it's like dude I want to see more of
that crazy shit I want to see them kiss
yeah so yeah that stuff was kind of
boring but the awkward dialogue that was
fun just because it's so weird for sure
I think I'll say the most believable
part of the movie is that Sean Connery
is Egyptian damn right it's a movie
about Scotland why are you having Sean
Connery play the Egyptian what's wrong
like one day they were smoking weed
hilarious sense of humor sure it was
silly it was so silly though so much fun
and it was just so going all the way
with it whatever it was it was going all
the way with it except for the gay
romance come on you show going all the
way with that but well it's a little
difficult for me but I guess I'll say
nein simply cut something like I said
cop scenes were boring it's tough I had
a blast man Wow okay I was
give it a seven and a half I am so much
I would go I really want to doing this -
a crazy just so I can watch it again cuz
as we're watching we're just throwing
something jokes and I'm like you're
gonna be fun well if we do that can I
please play the character who only does
chores and laughs yes
even after we find out the terrible
thing that happened yeah that was Nelson
legit like what a like holy shit oh yeah
especially in that dr. claw
[Music]
[Applause]
you